at least so you can see something but uh
hi there laura
what it was is that you had the rows and
rows
of uh mostly state troopers that
appeared to me uh as they were coming in
that direction and they uh
they said your media dispersed so uh
there wasn't any uncertainty
in the command they were given out and
they're trying to maintain order so
uh the right thing to do is go along
with those commands and also
as a matter of safety too there were
certainly a number of people in this uh
crowd who uh looked like and said they
were intent on
causing trouble and uh they weren't
obeying the orders to disperse the tear
gas the non-lethal weaponry came out
and the rose and rosa police officers
came out and that's the scene now in
front of the headquarters at uh
at brooklyn center laura and mike the
mayor i believe said tonight and
predicted that a curfew
would not have affected uh or
or decreased the level of violence that
might occur on the street or the unrest
if that's what we're calling it
does that look like given the fact that
we have as you said the usual
props of umbrellas and black backpacks
loaded up with lord knows what does that
look like he was making a considered
call there about the curfew to you
well i can't tell you you know as far as
a considered call would go
uh but i can tell you this the uh the
makeup of the population out here
certainly changed tonight i think uh
sunday night
it was all about the the locals who were
here and they were genuine
and they were angry as it goes on you
get more people coming in from out of
town
i had a lot of people or several people
i spoke with tonight who identified
themselves as
antifa and angrily so um
so you had that crowd out here and again
tonight i saw an increased number
of the uh kids wearing the uniform if
you will
the black hoodies the backpacks uh i saw
leaf blowers out there
um yeah different kinds of uh well we
saw it last night the makeshift shields
and things of that nature
but it was changing uh dramatically
in terms of the makeup of the crowd and
certainly the numbers of the crowd this
was the biggest
uh crowded demonstrators that we have
seen uh ever since sunday when this all
got started laura
now mike some of the protest groups that
i'm following uh
right now on social media are warning
other activists that they're picking up
on police scanners the plans to do
mass arrests of protesters
which i guess is just ticking them off
even more
but apparently according to police
scanner reads and this is from three
different
sources i don't know why they would make
this up are being planned
along the strip mall to the north of the
bcpd
area so that's something that we should
also
take a look out for because look the
mayor of
saint paul and the mayor of
minneapolis both said that they're they
they would not tolerate looting
and violence they both made that clear
uh despite
you know what we saw last night and the
night before
yeah they say they won't toddler
tolerate looting and violence but there
is still
uh looting and violence and then you had
the uh um the mayor
uh mike elliott of uh uh this town uh
suggests
as as you noted uh that if there was a
curfew it was being forced
essentially what he it sounded like he
was saying is that you're drawing a line
in the sand
it gives him something to defy and then
it creates a dynamic he said an excuse
for uh for more arrests in terms of
gearing up for more
for mass arrests i think that's what
ryan cops always do every time you see
riot cops they've got the
the zip strips with them and as we saw
uh last night there were upwards of
40 arrests that were made so uh when you
start defining mass arrests
you know when you're counting by uh in
numbers of 10 uh i think that would
constitute a mass arrest
in a situation like this we have a bunch
of people they declared unlawful
assembly
they got on the lrad a number of times i
counted at least four times
that they said it's a legal assembly
you've got to disperse you've got x
amount of minutes uh they started with
10 minutes and kept decreasing
and ultimately they moved in i think
it's very likely that
you will see some kind of mass arrest
and i'm looking in front of me as we're
driving along trying to get to a better
location
uh i'm watching just rows and rows of
humvees
uh from the national guard pulling uh
you know that some two thou
two thousand guardsmen uh have been
activated uh for this so uh their
numbers are showing up laura
yeah well again you're seeing pictures
live pictures
uh from the minneapolis area but
brooklyn center
where we saw massive unrest
criminality some peaceful protests the
night
a few nights before but overwhelmed by
what looks like again people who
believe that you know what happened to
mr wright was a criminal act not an
accident
and apparently mike there was concern
that
the police chief referenced an accident
at one point that it was an accidental
shooting
which sent a lot of these activists into
the stratosphere like how could you say
this was an
accident that's another thing that we
picked up uh in the last couple of hours
yeah it i think you picked that up
throughout the day anyone doubting uh
that it could have been an accident
and doubting that the mistake that they
say happened
that uh she mistook her her firearm for
her taser
and uh and they just simply doubt that
that happened you also heard in the
press conference with
mayor elliott today and the new acting
police chief
where the activist journalists were
there
uh uh really badgering uh the
the police chief the acting police chief
who'd been on the job for a half
hour um about the unlikelihood that they
thought it was
a an expired tag that motivated the
initial traffic stop
with dante wright uh that they believed
it was a profile stop and they were
asking him what he was gonna do
uh about profiling and uh his response
frankly was that he'd been on the job
less than an hour
and he didn't have a plan yet laura